hugh jackman announced that after the
next Wolverine movie he will be stepping
down from the role yeah apparently they
are already holding auditions for
Jackman's replacement we were able don't
ask me how to get ahold of the Wolverine
audition tapes I looked at them I think
Jackman is going to be very hard to
replace
take a look Thomas Middleditch and best
there is at what I do but what I do best
Thomas Middleditch but what I do best
isn't very nice shield marvel's agents
of shield I've tweeted twice now with
Clark Craig
[Applause]
[Music]
Quadra Hannibal Buress I'm I'm the I'm
the best there isn't what I do but what
I do best isn't very nice I feel like
I'm more of a gambit this is Bob right
oh sure
but if you want to shoot me then she
you've already lost your money if you
keep this up you'll lose something else
[Applause]
[Applause]
my name is Hugh Jackman is Australian so
I think it's a good idea to keep it you
know within the Queen's realm are the
names okay we're good thank you
if the Ghostbusters already been slimed
and primed ready to fight some ghosts
this is for Wolverine oh really
Hugh Jackman thank you for your time
Warren just curious why me is it because
of this
here very good hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please